all right kayla
kayla uh where'd you where'd you grow up
where you from originally uh i was born
in sevierville tennessee
but i've been in north carolina since i
was five
i'm 29 so and you came to west virginia
at what age
last year last august oh so you're new
here yeah yep
i came up here uh last august
with my ex so a man brought you here
yeah yeah how different is
this south western part of west virginia
to where you grew up in tennessee or
north carolina
uh from tennessee
i guess it's a lot different because
it's a tourist community so during the
summer time it's
packed full of people and during the
winter time it's
empty just very rural all the time yeah
it's it's the same people
all the time it's the same places all
the time it's
winston-salem it's so big and there's so
many
people it's different people all the
time you know
so it's definitely different here
compared to winston or tennessee because
it's always the same
the same thing all the time and how was
your childhood you grew up with
both your parents uh no my mom left my
step-dad or my mom left
my dad when i was 17 months old married
his brother
uh so from 17 months to when i was five
it was daddy uncle
uncle daddy how would you describe your
childhood
i don't really remember a lot of my
childhood um
i was uh musted when i was six by my
uncle
and doctors say that's why i don't
remember a lot of
people being your mom's second husband
my mom's no my mom's brother
okay i'm losing track a bit but i know
because it was it was daddy uncle
that's that kind of throws things off
but uh
that started at six did how long did
that last it just happened once
uh then i can recall anyways um
but no she didn't she still doesn't
believe that
it happened your mom didn't believe you
no she still doesn't
um she doesn't believe the doctors or
anything she believes what she wants to
she's an alcoholic
so i guess addiction kind of runs in our
family yeah that happens a lot
yeah how far did you go in school
10th grade uh
not my choice uh my step
or my real dad uh i went to
i went to high school and pigeon forge
he kind of
lost his mind a little bit over
christmas uh
he didn't have weed he's like jekyll and
hyde if he doesn't have his pot
and uh he sent me away for christmas and
when i came back he
just wasn't right and i stayed with my
cousin for a few days and he
called and told me to come get my stuff
and i'm scared to go to school after i
came and
went to the house and got my things and
come to find out he found out
truancy was the thing and so he put a
warrant out for me being run away
i turned myself in and spent a few days
in juvenile hall
and uh
they released me into his custody and he
beat the [ __ ] out of me
almost killed me and i just never went
back to school after that
i want to but
life just hasn't really given me that
opportunity yet
but did you you went on your own at what
age
what quit school yeah when you went out
on your own and lived without you
oh i i've always kind of lived
with my parents um i've always ended up
going back home to my mom's
it's always been back and forth back and
forth i've been homeless
i was homeless in new orleans i was
homeless in michigan and i was homeless
in
florida uh but all of this has just been
over the last five years
is it because of drugs uh
drugs it started because of depression
uh in a in a man
i got started on crack because of a
previous relationship and i seeked
their my kid's dad for help and
you know told him what was going on and
asked him to keep the kids for a little
bit longer and
next thing i know he's telling me that
he's not giving him back
and i haven't seen her spoke to them in
almost five years
and you have how many kids i have two i
have a eight-year-old daughter and a
six-year-old son and they're staying
with their dad and his girlfriend
yeah she's she's a big blessing
if it weren't for her there's no telling
where my kids would be at
so she she works through full-time jobs
and
make sure that they have everything that
they want and need and
they get to their doctor's appointments
and he's still a deadbeat but
at least he's got the babies i guess
but it's nice they're taken care of by
somebody yeah and that you like her
yeah i didn't
i mean i don't i wouldn't say that i
like her well you're you're
but i'm thankful for her so
and how do you support yourself now um
uh all kinds of different ways
if i can find work then i'll do it i do
everything from painting to
concrete to drywall um
flooring i can lay flooring
to having to turn tricks
yeah a lot of the girls do that yeah
i mean it's it's easy using fast money
it's
really degrading and it really is
uh it hits you hard and
in your self respect and you know your
self worth because it kind of makes you
feel
a little bit worthless but do you feel
bad about doing it afterwards oh yeah
yeah because i mean that's not who i am
that's not what i want to do
you know i want to do those things with
somebody that i actually care about you
know but
i mean i want to eat too and i want to
get high
what is your drug today uh heroin yeah
so when you need it you need it yeah
like right now i'm
a little under the weather you know but
my day was just getting started like i
just woke up i found you
yeah yeah i woke up and
came straight over that way do you have
any friends
i have a lot of friends here i wouldn't
call them friends um
i have one good friend he is actually
who i've been staying with
um his name's roy he's he's pretty cool
um i definitely wouldn't call them
friends because friends don't lie to one
another they don't steal from one
another
and everybody steals from you here
but i know a lot of people you know so
that's kind of helpful
give anyone you trust no
not here anywhere um
just god i don't even trust myself
really
but i do trust god so
are you religious more so
spiritual i guess i mean i think every
religion is right
because at the end of the day whether
you believe in that doorknob over there
you believe in yourself as your god
you still believe in something bigger
than what you are
so i don't know i guess i would say i'm
more so spiritual
i believe that i like to think there's a
god
you know that's why i'm still here
but i shouldn't be are you happy
no
you get depressed sometimes
what's been the toughest part of your
life losing your kids
yeah my family
what's been the best time of your life
being mom
do you ever consider leaving this this
area oh god every day
every day it's a tough region i mean it
seems like everyone is into drugs and
there's all kinds of other crazy things
going on here
yeah i mean if i go back home i'm still
gonna be using
but uh
i'll be around people that
act like they care more at least even if
they don't
they at least act like they do you know
i've got more places that i can stay so
i don't have to worry about being cold
during the winter time
but it's closer to my kids that i know i
can't
be near so it kind of helps being
further away
this is a very difficult part of the
country it seems that so many people are
into drugs
oh yeah i mean it's it's it's really bad
here that's all i hear about all the
time is
so and so died so and so d and you know
there was
there was a guy here named too tall
and he was they went up into his house
and they cut him ear to ear
while he sat in his recliner and then
everybody just ran up into his house
while there was still crime scene tape
up and
stole all of his stuff out of his house
like people are so heartless here
because
all they care about is getting high and
how they're going to get that next
that next buzz or just even really now
you're not even getting high
now you're just getting well but
it seems like there's so many it looks
like such a beautiful
and serene part of the country and yet
you start hearing all these stories of
yeah crazy human behavior it's uh
oh i don't know what the word would be
for that
it's it's [ __ ] up that's the word for
it
that's the word i think it's it's such a
beautiful place that's what makes me
want to stay
here but the people are just so ugly
it's
it's unreal you know in some parts of
the state maybe here maybe not
there's sex trafficking going on yeah
yeah i mean it's real i didn't believe
it
until i met some people i mean
they kidnap kids they kidnap women
you know i mean every time i go out
whether it's day or night i
you know i have to fear especially if i
get into somebody else's car i have to
worry about
whether or not i'm going to be shipped
off
to another state or across the border
you know i've met three people here just
in the last year that have been
kidnapped
uh i don't really know what happened to
them or
anything but i know that they were
kidnapped and they were
held hostage in a place you know so
that's
scary you don't think that those kind of
things happen right here you know
where you live at that's something that
happens in mexico or
california maybe you know but not in
west virginia
here it's so it's everyone is so rem
everything is so remote that it would be
easy to get away with
yeah you want to kill somebody and throw
them in a ditch oh yeah
you go up to irish mountain nobody would
ever know that
i mean there's so many places in the
woods here like there's places that i've
gone
and and walked into and i'm like damn
this would be a killer place to hide a
body
you know coyotes and the bears would
find it before anybody oh yeah
i mean it's it's scary i mean at any
point in time
i mean your whole life could just stop
and be over with
because of somebody else and it's
crazy to think that but it's
real you have to and people don't think
about that unless they're living this
lifestyle and it's
a shame because even if i'm
not getting high and i'm working a
full-time job at the hospital and i'm
i go home my two kids could be gone they
could have been outside playing and
got snatched up and
people don't think about that you know
you
people need to watch their kids a little
bit better and
and keep them close you know and watch
yourself
because there's people out here that
don't care
they really really really don't care
i mean they'll send you off and put you
in a house with 10 other
hispanic males taking care of them and
[ __ ]
all of them you know like kind of
it's not something anybody should have
to go through
what's the craziest thing you've seen
there's a few people here that when they
get high it's like
it's like they're being exercised like
they're possessed and they're being
exercised like they
they contort and convulse and smack
themselves and
i mean it's and there's been times that
i've seen them do this and we're doing
the same exact
stuff i'm like
it just drives me wild to think like
there's i mean is it something in their
brain that makes them act like that when
they get high why
and why why would you want to get high
if it makes you act like that
like i would be embarrassed
kind of to have people see me
behave in that manner when i got high
like i get high and i just
take a nap if i get high but
like i don't know if i got high and that
happened to me i wouldn't get high
anymore
what do you think the core of drug abuse
is depression is it something that
happened in your childhood that you're
trying to numb the pain of
i mean it could be your it could be your
childhood it could be your
early adult life i mean i didn't start
using drugs until i mean i did i messed
with cocaine back when i was like 17
18. but i quit for years never touched
anything but we
and when me and my kids dad separated
and i
got into a new relationship new kids
i just i something snapped and i
got started getting depressed and i was
24
before i started getting high you know
and i used to say that i would never in
my life ever stick a needle in my arm
and now i do it
50 times a day you know
i have to now it's to the point where i
have to go
chase money to go chase dope to go chase
somebody to help me
do my dope because i can't do it myself
you know it's it's tiring
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
it doesn't matter how bad people are to
you
if you feel like you're a good person
then continue to be a good person
don't be petty like everybody else just
because somebody
stole from you doesn't mean that it's
okay to steal from them
you know i don't know i just try to
through all the bad things that i've
seen i still try to be a good person
and help as many people as i can even
though i can barely help myself
you know if i can get somebody else high
then you know make them feel better for
the day then
you know cool if i can help somebody eat
something
that hasn't ate in a couple of days then
that's cool
you know but just
it's important it was it's important to
me to
just always be a good person
because there's so much ugly out there
yeah all right kayla thank you so much
for talking with me yeah
good luck with uh everything and and i
hope you get your kids back
thanks yeah me too you'd be a great mom
yeah i was how old are you
you're still twenty-nine young yeah i
feel so old
um my daughter her name's lily she's
um she's eight she was born september
11th
2012 and then my son liam he was born
6 27 14.
yeah they're they're good babies they're
beautiful too
i got lucky